the outcome of a coin flip is completely
random only it's not random at all if
I'd known exactly how the coin started
and what forces acted on it and if I
could do the calculations quick enough I
could have predicted the outcome it only
looked random because there were these
hidden variables I didn't take into
account we'll call this classical
randomness because this is the only type
of randomness allowed in classical
physics things only look random because
we don't know all the factors
influencing them the situation in
quantum mechanics though is quite
different remember we met the
wavefunction last time and we said it
contains each of the possible things the
particle could be doing as we know when
someone or something looks it has to be
doing just one of those things though
for example in the double slit
experiment if we put detectors behind
each door we'd see each particle go
through just one slit but which one
standard quantum mechanics says that
this is truly random unlike in classical
physics there is no extra information
you could get or extra calculations you
could do that could let you predict
which it will be it's not that the
particle really was doing one thing all
along if you hadn't measured it it would
still be in a superposition but when you
do look it has to choose only one option
and because that choice is truly random
there is no cause for it there is no
reason why this particle is measured at
door one and not door two but that
doesn't mean that every option is
equally likely consider this example we
do the double slit experiment again but
this time we put one of the doors a bit
far away we still don't know which door
the particle went through so it must
still be in a superposition of going
through both but if we measure it it
should be more likely to go through the
closer door right this fact is reflected
in the wavefunction through those
coefficients that I've been ignoring in
this example they could be these numbers
you interpret this as the bigger the
number the more likely the corresponding
state is to happen in this example the
probability that the particle is
measured at the
the door is 3/4 and the far door is 1/4
the exact mathematical rule for this is
very simple but it's a bit of a tangent
at the moment so I'll put that in a
short video by itself quantum mechanics
does have an element of true
unpredictability but that doesn't mean
that the theory is useless you can't
predict where one particular particle is
going to go from its wavefunction but if
there are a bunch of particles with that
wavefunction quantum mechanics lets you
predict their overall behavior very
accurately there's one other aspect of
the measurement rule that measurement
causes the wavefunction to collapse
say something measures a particle and
finds it in a particular state
what does the wavefunction look like now
remember the rule is that the
wavefunction is in a superposition of
all possible states but now only this
state is possible and so the
wavefunction collapses to just this this
actually has a dramatic effect in the
double slit experiment if I measure
which slit each particle goes through
that collapses their wave function so
that now each particle really is just
going through one door that means
they're not interfering with themselves
and so we get the regular pattern the
particles land in two bunches so here's
an interesting scenario say Bob is
measuring which door each particle goes
through Bob sees this particle go
through slit one so he says the
wavefunction collapses to this but what
if Bob didn't tell Alice his result is
the wavefunction collapsed for her or
not is there an experiment she could do
to tell feel free to pause the video if
you want to think about it
the answer is if one person or thing
does the measurement it doesn't matter
if no one else knows the result the
wavefunction is collapsed this is a bit
surprising because imagine if Alice goes
and measures which slip the particle
goes through straight after Bob her
result looks completely random to her
just as if the particle was in a
superposition but this isn't true
randomness anymore she'll get the same
result as Bob but since she doesn't know
his result it looks random just because
she's missing that information instead
what she should do is look at the
pattern on the screen as we said just
before because the wavefunction is
collapsed she'll see the particles land
in two bunches this explains one of the
big questions about quantum mechanics
why don't we see quantum weirdness all
the time why don't I see an interference
pattern when I throw apples and don't
watch which door they go through because
even if I'm not watching plenty of other
things are the Apple will interact with
light and air and make sounds etc and
they collapse the wavefunction for me so
quantum superpositions are rare because
they're so fragile we talk about quantum
effects with very small particles in
very controlled environments because
those particles really aren't
interacting with much and so they can
stay in a superposition and now you guys
know the two parts of the measurement
rule first the outcome is random but the
probabilities come from the coefficients
in the wavefunction and second after a
measurement the wavefunction collapses
and so it's question time first what if
there are three slits and you only have
a detector at one what does the wave
function of a particle that goes through
look like before and after the second
question is about what counts as a
measurement I kind of implied that
interactions with air and light count do
you think all interactions are
measurements what about if a machine
does a measurement and then without
storing in a memory prints the result
and burns it is the wave function still
collapsed and finally one about
interpretations
what do you think of quantum randomness
do you understand why some physicists
had a problem with it as you may know
there are hidden variable alternatives
to quantum mechanics that don't have
true randomness does this make them more
appealing is there anything you don't
like about in variable theories finally
thank you all so much for your answers
to the slightly more philosophical
questions last time and sorry I fell
behind answering I'm really looking
forward to your answers this time